there's something so freeing about
feeling like
i'm 40 and i look i'm in the best shape
of my life and
i want to post a bikini studying if i
want to
kim kardashian reveals whether she'll
dial back her sexy pics on social media
as she continues her journey to becoming
a lawyer
you just gotta roll with it in a sneak
peek for part one of keeping up with the
kardashians reunion special on
e host andy cohen asks the mama 4 if
she's considered turning down the heat
on her social media
as she moves forward in her law career
and she specifically recalls one time
she visited the white house
and was nervous about posting a bikini
pic beforehand
i thought about this and then i thought
you can do it all you can do whatever
you want
kim notes that she wants to be herself
but does have moments of doubt
mostly with regards to her kids there's
something so freeing about feeling like
i'm 40 and i look i'm in the best shape
of my life and
i want to post a bikini studying if i
want to
there's something powering about that
but then there's also like
i also want to don't want to embarrass
you know my kids or make them feel away
if they're in high school and i'm the
embarrassing mom that's like
posing you know in selfies and in
bikinis there will be limits
the famous fam then reveals that they
sometimes run their sexy pics by each
other
before they post it to social media and
yes
sometimes they do say it's too much it
was a photo i wanted to post from my
last trip
and she sent it two days in a row
thinking we wouldn't wouldn't remember
that it was the same photo
the day before and it didn't and you
listened to them i listened to them but
it's national peach day soon and i was
debating
definitely do not post the photos
also during part one of the reunion
special fans will see chloe open up
about carrying a heavy load on the show
and giving up so much of her personal
life kim and i have had this
conversation really openly is that
we feel like we give so much and maybe
others aren't holding up their end
of the deal too if if other people are
going through things and are choosing
not to share
that's when it's unfair but if there's
really nothing else going on in
someone's life what
are they supposed to do the 36 year old
good american founder gives her sister
courtney props for being super
transparent with fans about the ups and
downs in her relationship with scott
disick
during the show's earlier seasons but
says after seeing how that played out
publicly
court had a change of heart i think
court learned from
how much the public was in her
relationship with scott it made her not
want to share
future dating relationships and we
weren't even allowed to talk about it
we're not saying to put him on but
courtney wouldn't even let us
mention even though there's paparazzi
photos so we were
frustrated that we couldn't even talk
about what courtney was doing
chloe doesn't mention any of court's
former flames by name
but the 42 year old reality star was
previously linked to model eunice
benjamin from 2016 to early 2020.
of course the push founder is now dating
blink 182 drummer travis barker
and while fans didn't get to watch them
fall in love on keeping up
a source tells e.t that viewers can
expect to see the musician on the
family's new hulu show
along with the rest of her famous family
quote travis is expected to make an
appearance on the kardashians hulu show
his kids may appear as well but not as
much as he will be featured
i love it until then fans will just have
to tune into part one of the keeping up
reunion when it airs june 17th on e you